so could you firstly Define the term
Ramadan
alhamd the word Ramadan is derived from
the Arabic word ramid orad which means
intense scotching heat and dryness it's
also derived from the Arabic word
ramda which means sunbaked sand in
Islamic terminology the word Ramadan it
signifies I the intense heat in the
stomach due to
thirst when a Muslim fast The Thirst
that is there it produces heat in the
stomach which is defined as
Ramadan again
Ramadan it has another meaning it means
that the good deeds they Scorch the sins
and the evil of a Muslim so Ramadan is a
month in which the sins are scorched
Away by The Good Deeds like how a sun
scorches the ground in the same way
and heat normally it helps in forming
molding or
reshaping virtually every matter in the
same way Ramadan helps in molding
shaping and reforming the
spiritual and the moral aspects of the
human being
that the reason we term this word asan
second definition of terms if you like
is s or
fast as it's sometimes or mostly it's
translated in English um could you shed
some light on what are the implications
of the term fast or s s is Arabic word
which is singular Sam is plural
s in Arabic is derived from the word
Sama which means to abstain or to
restrain from the normal things whether
it be eating drinking or talking and a
person who observes some or abstains
from these things is called as aim and
this word is used in the Quran in Surah
chapter number 19 verse number 26 when
the angel speaks to Mary may Allah be
pleased with her who is the mother of
Jesus Christ peace be upon him and this
word is used and if you read this word
says that I have vowed to fast to
Allah but here the meaning of the word s
fast doesn't mean refraining from eating
or drinking it means refraining from
speaking because when we go to the
context when we read one verse before in
the Quran Surah maram chapter number 19
verse number 25 it says that Allah subh
say says to Mary may Allah be PE with
her that shake the palm tree towards
yourself and the r dates will fall and
the next verse suram chapter 19: 26 says
eat and drink from them and then it says
that when you meet any human being tell
them I have vowed to fast for Allah and
I will not speak to any human being so
because here it says about speaking the
word s used here means
that to abstain from
speaking but the word s in Islamic
terminology in the Islamic Sharia it
means a
person who does an act of
worship and with intention he does it
for the sake of Allah subhana tala and
he or she
abstains from eating drinking or
nourishment as well as from sexual
intercourse or from lustful s
ejaculation in short the word s in Islam
means a person who abstains from the
fast breakers and the fast breakers the
things that break the fast are food
whether taken by mouth or by nose or
drink any kind of drink whether it be
water milk fruit juice any drink taken
from mouth or nose or any nourishment
for the body taken from any
source as well as abstaining from a
sexual
intercourse in short it means
abstaining the stomach and the private
part this is what it means
islamically
and this is the basic meaning but if you
go ahead with the broader meaning it
does not mean only abstaining the
stomach and the sexual part from the
things that break the fast it even means
that along with the fasting of the
stomach and the sexual parts there is
fasting of the tongue of the eyes of the
ears and the other limbs of the body
that is the reason when we use the word
s our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallah
wasallam said it's mentioned
inkari volume number three in the book
of fasting Hadith number 1903 I beloved
Prophet said that a person who does not
abstain does not leave false action and
false speech obsin Etc Allah does not
require of him to abstain from food and
drink that means beside abstaining from
food and drink you also have to abstain
from false speech false actions Etc and
this message is further repeated my
beloved Prophet wasallam our beloved
Prophet MMI wasallam said in say of
number one number
1068 Bel Prophet said that a
person while fasting when he abstains
from food and drink he should also
abstain from false speech from obscene
language and if a person gets angry and
if he argues with him or fights with him
he should say I'm fasting I'm
fasting so if we look at it when a
person fast there are basically three
things that he should abstain from
number one is the stomach and the
private parts they should
abstain from things that break the fast
that is food drink and sexual act the
second is that the other parts of the
body the tongue the eyes the ears the
limbs even they should
fast fasting of the tongue means a
person should abstain from backbiting
should abstain from sanding from telling
a
lie should abstain from gossing abstain
from rumor
mongering abstain from
vulgarity fasting of the eyes means he
should abstain from looking at things
which are
unlawful like when he said he should
lower his gaze he should not watch un
Islamic
movies or un Islamic things fasting of
the years means should abstain from
hearing things which are Haram which are
prohibited like abstain from listening
to music abstain from listening to songs
which are un
Islamic so this is the way how the other
parts of the body also fast and the
third thing is the fasting of the heart
and the mind they should abstain from
things which take away person from the
worship of Allah from the vi of Allah so
this overall is the meaning of the word
s Subhan Allah it certainly has a lot
more
involved in it than I was expecting
thank you Dr Zak